john
yeah that's the last thing you would
probably want is showing up on a date
with someone and you think it's
something and it's
not
uh let's switch gears at least and talk
about uh luxury thing you think it's
something oh my goodness i was i was
trying to keep it yeah let's
at least sorry
let's let's switch gears quite literally
at least let's talk about luxury cars
luxury car makers the rolling says some
eco-friendly models what are the details
here
more than a dozen high-end automakers
are showing off their latest hybrid and
electric models at monterey car week in
california the brands on display include
rolls royce and mclaren lamborghini is
even debuting its brand new countach the
car with the car maker says the
sustainable vehicle can hit 60 miles per
hour in less than three seconds the
price tag 2.5 million dollars so if
you're in that car and you show up and
the person your tinder date isn't right
you can just take right off yeah right
so if you're if your tinder profile
shows a lamborghini countach and you
show up in a nissan sentra that's going
to be a bit of a shock to this system
that'll set you back a little bit
yeah that's why we need to have the
verification